my name is fabian cousteau fabian is an
aquanaut an ocean explorer today i'm
going to break down some clips from
movies and tv about ocean exploration so
let's dive in exploring the ocean the
life aquatic with steve
[Music]
zizu it's a little close to home there
are many different types and shapes of
submersibles or submarines from military
use uh they could be quite large and
quite comprehensive two scientific
submersibles that contain just one
person breathing underwater pirates of
the caribbean curse of the black pearl
this is either madness or brilliance i
love this movie but that's actually
plausible if the boat is heavy enough to
hold the air for a short amount of time
there's enough oxygen in that breathing
loop to be able to do that air pockets
form in things that are concave so like
a cup being forced under water but
that's the key is is the boat heavy
enough to not float up to the surface
with an air bubble additionally scuba
diving and ocean exploration under the
blue veneer was first started with this
similar kind of concept so this is
feasible so it would seem
ocean currents finding nemo
what brings you on this far day to the
eac
yeah so ocean currents are absolutely
real deep ocean currents uh are
basically conveyor belts connecting the
various oceans of the world many animals
that are transients actually use ocean
currents for transportation so it is
absolutely possible to find these kinds
of turtles and others in these kinds of
currents because they've been using them
for hundreds of millions of years to
transport them from point a to point b
ships
the beatles yellow submarine
usually we listen to
sounds of nature because we have to be
very attentive to the radio from the
surface to other sounds around us in the
water well my grandfather built some of
the first underwater submersibles for
scientific research and in order to
distinguish a submersible for military
use versus a submersible for scientific
research the research submarines were
painted yellow high visibility so you
can see them easily and distinguish
themselves from other purposes and so
the color yellow is very typified in
underwater research submersibles now
that said that's not the only color
there's white there's orange there's
many other colors but yellow is by far
the most common color i kind of like the
way it is losing oxygen into the blue
so many things are wrong with the scene
first of all you shouldn't be low or out
of air if you are you should be with
your buddy who can share air with you
this is an analog pressure gauge very
common and it's buried in the zero mark
which means that he just ran out of air
completely and that's an extremely
dangerous scenario and one that you're
trained to avoid
yo
look at this where's amanda he of course
understandably went straight to the
surface not blowing bubbles which you
should be blowing bubbles as you're
going to the surface otherwise you can
risk an embolism
grabbed a tank with no regulator on to
go back down in emergency circumstances
you can swap those tanks out underwater
if you know what you're doing but this
guy looks like he doesn't know what he's
doing fantasy underwater habitat star
wars one the phantom
menace almost everything in this scene
is total fantasy other than the free
diving aspect of course but what's
interesting is the miniaturized
apparatus that they put in their mouths
is actually mauled after uh something
that has been experimented with
in most fantasy renderings of underwater
habitats you see a dome and then you see
people in some sort of dry environment
underwater city that's kind of a hybrid
idea between what we as human beings
need which is a source of air a source
of breathing gas and some of these sea
creatures who can seemingly transition
from a water environment to an air
environment without any problem in
breathing that said we are building an
underwater city of sorts an underwater
research station more akin to the
international space station of the sea
called proteus proteus will be fully
equipped to take on at least 12 to 18
people to house a submarine in a
submarine hangar and to be able to
deploy aquanauts for indefinite periods
of time in the ocean and to live
underwater for not hours or days but
weeks months and possibly longer deep
diving gear the abyss give me your
reading after liquid oxygen gauge
there's some creative license taken in
this particular scene deep divers
typically do use suits somewhat like
this although this certainly looks like
a spacesuit the
suit itself apparently is equipped with
liquid breathing we're reading at the
liquid oxygen gauge which up to this day
is not feasible the idea of liquid
breathing is exactly that it's breathing
liquid that's rich in oxygen so that it
sustains life what we typically use on
expeditions
are
full face masks which
fit the entirety of your face up front
and that gives us the advantage of being
able to have multiple different kinds of
attachments on there including in this
case an open circuit pod we can switch
this out to a closed circuit pod which
allows us to use rebreathers and
additionally it gives us the ability to
have communications so we'd have a
microphone in here and we'd be able to
communicate amongst each other
underwater and to the surface the meg
i'd love to have that habitat that looks
pretty cool with the tube and everything
else there are several things wrong with
that clip first of all scale uh there's
no shark of that size in existence today
it just simply doesn't exist
oh boy that's you like that please the
injury that it sustained getting sliced
open like that may not have killed it
right away but it certainly would have
injured a shark enough so that it would
have broken off an attack
and lastly i've never seen so many
different species of shark in one
particular screen or one particular
glance real interesting but a total
fantasy at the end of the day
there are only about 90 to 95 shark
incidences worldwide of which a dozen
are fatal which is tragic but compare
that to the 120 million sharks we
slaughter every year who should be
afraid of who ocean myths atlantis and
aquaman
i want to live there
atlantis has been a common myth since
the greek legends and it may be based in
some aspects of history where
earthquakes may have swallowed up a near
shore village and sunk it to the bottom
of the sea
the ocean swallowed us
and atlanta sank
people have been fascinated with the
ocean world since there have been people
on this planet because it's below the
blue veneer it's below that surface area
it's that mystery place that is full of
animals and sea creatures and aliens and
so it stands to reason that we would
hope and think and dream that there's an
underwater city down there somewhere oh
i know the story underwater exploration
the titanic
stay with us the titanic has been the
subject of pseudo legend for a century
one iceberg sank it right to the bottom
of the ocean and so between the
publicity and the notoriety of the
titanic it's become quite a legend
this particular clip in titanic actually
portrays a fairly accurate visual of
what you would see on a clear day
underwater especially at depth when you
happen on to a shipwreck with that kind
of light and those kinds of capabilities
that is quite possibly what you'd be
confronted with still gets me every time
you're really trying to set me up aren't
you
well hollywood has outdone itself yet
again first and foremost don't touch
anything you don't know in the water
ocean lake whatever just don't touch it
additionally uh laying eggs in long
strands like that i've never seen
especially from a piranha certainly
aims to be quite an entertaining film
this is incredible
stranded open water
i don't know where's the boat i guess
it's one of those
they pretty much did everything that
they needed to do when they popped up
normally when a person goes for
recreational diving they have all the
basics including bcd mask fin snorkel
and tank in this scenario like in open
water two things that could save your
life and are easy to carry are a whistle
to signal attention to the closest boat
and a safety sausage which when you
inflate
comes up three to six feet depending on
the size of the sausage so that it
signals where you might be very simple
mechanisms easy to carry and can
potentially save your life one day
capturing fish finding nemo
it should be absolutely illegal to take
anything from the sea without any
specific permissions i would highly
recommend that you leave the coral reef
the way it is and just take pictures
because otherwise you could be subject
to some very strict rules by the
authorities you think you could do these
things but you just can't finding
treasure into the blue
they look like a bunch of yahoo divers
there are a lot of things that if you're
a professional treasure hunter or
archaeologist you simply don't do first
of all you always wear rash guard or a
wetsuit even in tropical waters
typically you don't hang on to each
other with one dpv or diver propulsion
vehicle
there are a lot of procedures that you'd
want to follow to do things
professionally uh this is definitely not
professional i can't believe this guy
the nerve twenty thousand leagues under
the sea take care of the tentacles
they'll seize anything within reach and
hang on to the death
[Music]
there are a lot of rumors why the giant
squid has become this mythological
animal i would imagine you find little
tantalizing bits of evidence washed up
on shore and the imagination
fills in the blanks and so you create a
sea monster giant
cephalopods including squid exist and we
haven't really done a good job at
finding them or filming them there have
been sailor stories of large animals
like giant squid sometimes wrapping
their tentacles around their boats i
would imagine that there may be a time
down the road where a deep sea
submersible not a large submarine like
nemo's but a small submersible may have
an encounter with a squid or some other
kind of cephalopod it's possible that it
may get curious and wrap its tentacles i
would imagine it wouldn't be able to
bring it down to the bottom but hey
they're pretty big animals
[Music]
[Applause]
the classic shark attack
jaws
[Music]
shooting a scuba tank in a shark's
mouth's probably not going to yield
those results typically shooting a scuba
tank allows for the air to pass through
the bullet hole and will make it act
like a rocket more than an explosion
diving the big blue
[Music]
there's many different kinds of free
diving from variable weight to constant
weight to assisted to unassisted in this
particular case the protagonist goes
down to the bottom on a sled so a
variable weight and goes to the depths
in the dark to experience the ocean i've
got to go and see those who do free
diving they would consider this a more
pure form of diving
i don't usually see free divers dive at
night but the rest of it is fairly
accurate defense against sharks
lara croft tomb raider cradle of life
first of all it's a giant shark coming
at her and she's punching with her
weight towards an animal that weighs 10
times which she was more
not realistic secondly uh sharks don't
yawn underwater it was a common practice
and common thought that punching a shark
in the nose was a good deterrent in case
you were face to face with an animal
that was aggressive we've since found
out that you actually have a good chance
of angering the animal smart sharks
deep blue sea
[Music]
they recognize that gun it's impossible
sharks do not swim backwards they can't
ah
what to say about that clip they're
right that sharks don't swim backwards
unless for short distances they can back
out of a corner or something like that
it's not realistic
shark cage 47 meters down
one of the first things that you do in
that kind of scenario is you have a
backup connection to the boat it's
almost impossible for something to fail
but if it does you're always attached to
the boat and you don't go sinking to the
bottom
there are several things that are very
real reactions for example if this is
your first time shark cage diving it's
very impressive it's a little can be a
little intimidating or scary are you
girls okay
no i think the cage just dropped a
little bit they do have auga master ago
type masks on for communications usually
you're on hookah and not on tanks when
you're in the shark cage but if god
forbid something like this would happen
they do have an air supply with them
more ships the life aquatic with steve
zizu here's where we do all our
different science projects and
experiments this is the kitchen which
contains probably some of the most
technologically advanced equipment on
the ship that clip comes very close to
home the calypso was my
my home growing up uh and the crew were
family the belafonte is quite similar in
that nature top side we've got the
bridge the mini sub and old chopper and
all kinds of radar and sonar and
underwater movie gadgets your typical
research vessel would be set up for
everything that you need for long-term
expeditions because in many cases
once you sailed off from port you would
be gone three four five six months
sometimes multiple years at a time so
you would need to bring with you
everything that you could a library for
all the research needed a galley of
course that was fully equipped
preferably with wine and of course some
laboratories to do experiments on site
for us it was also having a dive locker
and other vehicles so that we could get
to places that the ship just couldn't
equipment damage the abyss
oh [ __ ] that's what about what everyone
would say in that scenario having
equipment that's tethering you to the
surface coming down from the surface is
potentially uh devastating
taking away the fantastical aspects for
a moment teams such as the one in the
abyss are mimicking some of the
functionality of teams in exploration
for deep ocean in the realms of oil
exploration cable laying et cetera et
cetera et cetera diving gear men of
honor
[Music]
ah yes lead feet although i've never
been in the u.s navy this seems like a
fairly extreme test for the u.s navy
diver the equipment that he was donning
is hundreds of pounds and it is
extremely difficult to move in so you
have to be very well trained and great
physical shape they
used to use those for training in the
old days and it was commonplace
before scuba to use hard hat diving to
explore the bottoms of the ocean
underwater explosions lost
[Music]
underwater explosions have the potential
being quite devastating now what i'm
really curious about though is why
the young gentleman sealed himself
inside when he could just have easily
gone by the bulkhead and sealed himself
on the safe side of that explosion i
don't know
mother nature day after tomorrow
everyone's worse now no one's gonna
sleep after this someone in cities near
shore
so tsunamis huh tsunamis and large waves
can be triggered by many things
including tectonic plates shifting
luckily this is very rare but it does
happen it's happened in the south
pacific several times and unfortunately
lives get lost in this particular
fictitious scenario that's hundreds of
thousands if not millions of lives that
could be lost i guess if we lived on a
different planet that didn't have an
ocean then we could avoid these kinds of
issues but the reason why we exist the
reason why everything that we know we
love we cherish exists is thanks to the
ocean conclusion one of my goals in life
is to have people fall in love with the
ocean the way i did as a child as much
as i love hollywood and fiction the
reality of ocean is much more
mesmerizing it's pandora's box of
mysteries waiting to be uncovered it's a
very unique magical place that deserves
your attention